how does the sun manage to power our
entire solar system
i'm pretty sure the answer has something
to do with nuclear fusion but i don't
really know what that is so an expert is
going to explain it to me in a
two-minute elevator ride
[Music]
hey hannah hi
[Applause]
all rat 45 levels what is nuclear fusion
and how does it relate to the sun all
right let's just start with an atom so
you have the nucleus of two atoms and if
you can push them together they will
fuse and form a new element but this is
really difficult the nuclei of atoms are
positively charged and positive charges
repel the pressure has to be strong
enough to get these atoms to merge yeah
all right the sun contains 99.8
of the mass of the entire solar system
and all of it is basically hydrogen okay
so you've got this huge mass bearing
down onto the center why does it push
into the middle
gravity okay this pressure overcomes
that repulsion they undergo a process
called
quantum tunneling but that's another
lyft ride
and the hydrogen fuses into a new
element helium oh my gosh we're already
halfway through
okay this is high pressure okay so
exactly is that like because the sun's
burning isn't it he's not burning so
it's squeezing it is fusing and is that
like burning no burning is the chemical
combustion okay but fusion causes heat
and light it does we get energy out of
this reaction right so if you weigh the
two hydrogens that went into it with the
helium that came out the helium is
actually lighter but less mass matter
can't be created or destroyed exactly
but it can be converted and this matter
is converted into energy and you know
the equation for that
no
you do it
do i you do
e equals m squared that's right what
does that mean so it means energy and
mass are interchangeable and they can be
converted from one to the other and in
the case of the sun this mass is
converted into energy this is mostly in
the form of light and heat ah so the
nuclear fusion causes the sun to shine
that's right so that's why like nuclear
fusion reactors is a thing that exists
it doesn't exist we haven't been able to
harness fusion yet nuclear energy is
fission the splitting of an atom fusion
could be better if we can manage to
recreate the conditions inside the sun
on earth it would be a much cleaner way
to produce energy then we have literally
a limitless source of hydrogen that
seems really hard to make that much
pressure though
that's the challenge oh well maybe
someone will eventually figure it out
thank you hannah thank you back
so nuclear fusion is the process within
which two atoms get smushed together
under immense pressure until their
nuclei come together and form a new
element now in the case of the sun this
is happening with hydrogen to form
helium but if you were to weigh those
two atoms of hydrogen they actually
weigh more than the helium that comes
out at the end like how is this possible
well e equals m c squared the matter
that is getting lost is actually
converted into energy and in the case of
the sun that energy is heat and light so
essentially the sun is one huge nuclear
fusion reactor and if we can figure out
how to do the same thing here on earth
then we could produce tons of clean
energy imagine it just lots of little
suns all over planet earth it's pretty
cool stuff i'm glad i'm no longer in the
dark with this one
hey thanks for watching so in our chat
hannah mentioned quantum tunneling which
we actually covered in another episode
you can see a video for that here
and if you want more hannah then check
out our doco series catalyst we'll put
some details in the description below
bye for now